Sharla there are four books that you
believe every screenwriter should read
yeah first one being John truby's the
anatomy of story why why this book
I think that
new screenwriters
struggle with structure
and I think that new screenwriters
before they get comfortable with story
don't really recognize how innate story
is I think
I think even if you're a terrible
Storyteller like I'm a terrible
Storyteller like in a in a bar if I'm
telling a story I'll start with middle
I'll jump to the end all I have to like
retract to the beginning it's always I'm
a terrible Storyteller in the moment but
the story itself is there and the the
joy that you get even in a bar when
you're talking to your friends and
telling them a story and you are able to
build it up in a way that has people
hanging on your everywhere so that they
can hear the end of how this story goes
and like or the punch line of a joke
it's like the punch line of a joke the
end of the story and so I just kind of
feel like John truby's anatomy of story
breaks down story in a way that shows
how organic it is to us as human beings
how innate it is in us how we all know
how to tell a story and how story is
everywhere story is pattern
um story is
um
story is organic structure I feel like
I'm not necessarily explaining it in a
good way but I just think that the way
that he shows how every story is very
similar
um and using different different ways of
showing us how every story is
a pattern you know like I just think
that he's really he's just he's just
really explain it in a really smart way
I think so I think it's really good for
people to just get a broad understanding
of
of story and that's kind of what that
book does
the second book is the art of dramatic
writing why this book so this book I
love so much because dialogue was
something that I really struggled to
make feel natural I really struggled to
make my characters talk in a way talk
how I talk uh talk on my friends talk
but the scenes that I would be writing
were all very relatable scenes and
that's what the art of dramatic writing
talks about like I mean it talks about
starting with character it talks about
the importance of having a character
know what they want and having a
character struggle with something being
at the core of what makes them who they
are and like having something to
overcome and all all of this helping to
put words in their mouth on the page and
to also Drive story at the same time
just this idea that dialogue is story
dialogue Drive story dialogue is
character it's all these three things
wrapped up into one and every time your
character talks they reveal something
about themselves or about the scene the
situation it gives context every time
your character talks it pushes the story
forward it reveals something so just the
idea that like that dialogue is this
layering this unlayering this peeling of
an onion of helping us tell the story so
it's like I just I really love Legos
eager I I think that's how to pronounce
his name I love that book in particular
because I feel like it's like that next
level like if we start with John truby's
Anatomy a story to get the foundational
elements of what story is the next level
is the art of dramatic writing Legos
agree because it helps us
to help our characters tell the story
basically
third book is on writing by Stephen King
another Northeastern writer why this
book that book I think
just made me feel like okay I'm a writer
and I'll explain why and it's because
Stephen King sort of he he writes it
like a memoir like he really just writes
about his process the way that his mind
works he talks about his mind being very
chatty and descriptive in the same ways
that my mind
Works
um I can be very observant I can be
somebody that is usually more to myself
and that's because my mind is working
and kind of transcribing what's going on
around me and that's kind of how he
talks about writing he talks about the
necessity of being descriptive and the
way that good writing allows you to be
able to close your eyes the same way
that you can read a book and see a room
being described because the writing has
described it so well you know maybe he's
talking about the light cracking through
the window or the dampness of the wood
after it rained the night before or you
know these kinds of these kinds of
descriptive words really invoke sight
almost you can almost like see what he's
talking about and I think if
particularly if you're a screenwriter
um when your words are very much
describing a visual medium I think on
writing is a really really great book to
check out just in general General but
also in particular if you're a
screenwriter because of how important I
think it is to understand
um how our minds work when it comes to
writing well
the fourth book is the nutshell
technique by Jill Chamberlain the
nutshell technique is great because it's
one of those book like a lot of books do
this actually like there's there's
always some technique that someone tries
to show you when it comes to writing a
pilot script or writing a an episode of
television or a screenplay or something
like that it's really trying to
describe patterns and show you the ways
that
every story is pretty much the same
whether you're writing a screenplay or a
TV script or a novel
um you're writing similar stories and
she just talks about
um I'm I'm blanking on what she calls it
like she calls it like writing in an X
in a nutshell or something like that I
cannot remember like the specifics of
her book but it is a good it's one of
those books that talks about structure
for story and
how to I guess get the patterns down so
I think Jill Chamberlain's book is great
for that all four books have their own
controversy you know we've seen it in
different comments
how would you dispel some of that
controversy whether someone's saying uh
this technique is too formulaic this is
what's going to churn out and I'm just
I'm parroting what I've I've seen in
comments I don't personally feel this
but this is going to turn out a very
specific filmmaking we've all seen these
these movies
you've got to let the writer be free
I think that those points are valid
I think that they're misplaced though
and misunderstood because I think it's
very difficult to
write a good
screenplay or a good television script
without understanding a structure and
viewing structure as a cage instead of
as like I would say a boat you know
instead of viewing it as something that
kind of locks you in viewed as something
that helps to buoy your story like view
it as something that helps to deliver
your story because when you don't have
the structure you're not really able to
bring the story together in a way that I
think is
effective and cohesive and like hits the
person that is watching it and gets your
message across I think structure
is essential in order for you to play I
think it's essential in order for you to
be loose and creative uh learn the
structure so that you can forget about
it learn the structure so that you can
not have to think about it so that you
can just get your story out in the best
possible way I mean so stories have been
written written for thousands of years
I think to have the I almost want to say
the audacity but even just like the ego
to think that you know better than
thousands of years of Storytelling and
hundreds of people that have come
hundreds of thousands of millions of
people that have come before you and
have written novels and screenplays and
best-selling works of art it's like you
know we're telling you this because
we've been there I've been the person
that didn't wanna that wanted to forget
about structure I've been the person who
thought that it was too restrictive and
then I went around I went ahead and
tried to do it without it and what I
realized during that time was that oh I
never really understood it like what was
happening was that
it can be taught in a way that is so
formulaic and so dry and so not organic
to our our understanding of story that
it can just feel
like a math equation uh but I think that
once you actually understand it and I
actually think like the South Park guys
explain it the best because it's in this
like very easy way that anybody can
understand they say
um if your story goes this then this
then this then that then it's a bad
story but if your story goes this
happens
so this happens because that happened
therefore that happened therefore this
happens you know that story is about
causation it's about momentum it's about
things pushing things forward the reason
that we teach that your character your
story has to be character based and your
character can be anything it can be a
landscape but most likely it's a person
mostly like the history of your
character is important because the whole
story is about what they want and
whether or not they're gonna get what
they want you know
find it like I'm trying to think of the
best stories and like I'm just saying
that like
um structure
structure is in all of our favorite
stories you know it's in Finding Nemo
it's in Star Wars it's in it's in all
those stories and it's not a mistake
um it's there for a reason and it's
there to help you
and so from your time uh being in
writer's rooms or even with stand up or
or doing the working writer School
have you seen sort of the rage the the
people enraged over these screenwriting
books or no you've never encountered
some of the pushback I don't think it's
a rage I think it's like just you know
plain old frustration of being a writer
who wants to tell a story and struggling
to get it across in a way that that is
satisfying in a way that you know would
be satisfying to you and you've seen it
done in a satisfying way and you can't
figure out why you can't get it and I
would just encourage those people to
keep going keep writing the story poorly
keep writing it badly do as little bit
of it as possible uh bit by bit every
day if you can write if you can stand to
write it for 15 minutes 20 minutes an
hour
it doesn't have to be like three hours
of writing every day so that you can get
to your story you can do a little bit
every single day and you'll look up in a
month after 15 minutes every day of you
know
itching away scratching away at that
story
um you'll have something that you might
be happy with and I think it's just like
I think it's just about being able to
sit with the difficulty sometimes of
getting our stories across which they
are and they and I don't know why we
expect it to be easy
I almost think you should expect
difficulty and so if it's easy it'll be
a surprise but if it's hard you expect
it to be hard because telling a good
story is hard sometimes
and that's okay